[Applause]
[Music]
my body has been objectified my entire
career i was too big mother too small
and when you were heavier you were fine
i was and i was body positive then and
i'm body positive now but it's not my
job to validate how people feel about
their bodies
i'm trying to sort my own life out i had
no time to choose
once i realized that i had a lot of work
to do on myself yeah i stopped drinking
and i started working out lots and stuff
like that to keep me sort of centered
[Music]
adele performed four new songs for a
star-studded crowd that included leo
drake lizzo ellen and seth rogen 10
million people watched the cbs special
adele in a custom black scaparelli gown
her saturn earrings matching her new
tattoo symbolizing a turning point in
her life but what wasn't on tv hi
that's oprah pre-interview greeting
adele as she got ready in oprah's guest
house she also revealed where the
sit-down was almost held we thought of
doing it here right there in the center
but it didn't feel intimate
[Music]
and while adele may be the queen of
breakup songs she helped orchestrate
this surprise engagement that had the
audience in tears will you marry me have
you gotten over the shock
no i'm pretty sure i'm still shocked
right now this morning i spoke to the
happy couple what happens afterwards
oh my gosh so adele finishes the concert
first person comes running over is tracy
ellis ross gives us a big hug
congratulations and then uh oprah and
then drake
and kerry washington and just it was
just a lot it was a lot
the wedding now how do you top what
happened easy easy oprah rose garden
drake's backyard
love
congratulations
[Applause]
[Music]